people living on Florida's panhandle
could be just about 48 hours away from a
hurricane making landfall meteorologist
Danielle Niles of our Boston station WBZ
is tracking tropical storm Michael
Danielle good morning good morning
Michael has gained strength now just
sitting under hurricane status with 70
mile-per-hour winds and moving to the
north at 7 miles per hour passing just
to the east of Cancun and Cozumel
already some of the outer bands of
moisture impacting parts of southern
Florida right now the live satellite and
radar shows some downpours impacting Key
West to Key Largo and then back up over
the west coast of Florida where they're
expecting 2 to 4 inches of rain there
along the forecast track Michael is
likely to become a hurricane later on
today and strengthened to a category 2
storm by tomorrow into tomorrow night
taking aim along the Florida Panhandle
the exact track obviously still a cone
of uncertainty but puts the entire
Panhandle in the path from the Big Bend
over towards the Alabama border likely
to make a landfall as a category 2
weakening to 1 hurricane
overnight on Wednesday into Thursday and
pass over the Carolinas as a tropical
storm and sailing south and east of
Nantucket as we head into the upcoming
weekend so rainfall totals impressive
highest totals from Panama City through
Tallahassee but the deeper oranges and
reds indicating 4 to 8 inches of rain
freshwater flooding will be a huge
concern and obviously the surge as well
all the way from Indian past stretching
back down to Crystal River seven to
11-foot surge is possible John Wow
Danielle thanks